se muestra la gráfica de la línea 2 3 x
7 encuentra la intersección en x bueno
recordemos que la intersección en x es
el valor de x cuando ya vale 0 aquí lo
podemos ver y nos podemos más o menos
dar cuenta de que este punto para estar
un poquito más arriba del 2 pero sin
llegar al 2.5 para encontrar el valor
exacto veamos la ecuación 2 yemas 3 x
como queremos la intersección en x
estalle la vamos a sustituir por un 0 2
por 0 + 3 x igual a 7 2 por 0 0 nos
queda 3x igual a 7 y si dividimos todo
entre 3 esto entre 3 y esto entre 3 nos
queda que x es igual a 7 tercios a lo
mejor se ve un poco complicar esta
fracción si la transformamos a decimal
pero recuerden que esto es igual
seis tercios más un tercio y 4 663 pues
estos esto es igual a dos enteros un
tercio que es más o menos lo que se
alcanzaba en una tercera parte de aquí
arriba de este dos otra forma de verlo
es que este tres cabe dos meses en este
siete y nos sobra uno y ese uno hay que
dividirlo entre tres por lo que nos
queda de nuevo dos enteros un tercio